perdit et cas rappelle l'un des
interdiction de cumul d'emplois avec les
fonctions publiques qui prévoit code de
la défense droits et obligations des
fonctionnaires au cumul d'activités des
fonctionnaires et qui demandent
expressément que et qui rappelle à celui
qui nous pose la question qu'ils
exercent ou pas l'activité qui lui est
interdit de l'exercer dans les cadres ou
la loi lui interdit expressément de le
faire
nous sommes par a par contre face à une
difficulté je leur mets très
formellement porter ou du président
nous sommes par exemple par contre face
à une difficulté un militaire un
fonctionnaire de police un fonctionnaire
public qui prévoit sa retraite dans six
mois ou dans un an peut parfaitement à
ce titre demandé une demande de carte et
d'habilitation et l'exercé qu'au moment
où il n'est plus dans l'interdiction de
cumul il peut par ailleurs parfaitement
demandé à exercer le cumul notamment
s'il est employée à mi-temps ou dans
toute une série de dérogations qui
existe dans le code général de la
fonction publique qui sait de ce point
de vue là beaucoup élargie et a servi au
fil des ans et donc il faut le traiter
au cas par cas
par ailleurs comme ceci vous avez été
indiqué je crois précédemment nous
contrôlons normalement les cartes tous
les cinq ans c'est ce que faisaient les
préfectures depuis les problématiques
général indique notamment de lutte
antiterroriste des processus dit de
lutte contre la radicalisation
nous avons fait un contrôle général
avant l'euro 2016 pour des raisons qui
paraissait légitime à tous nous faisons
désormais un contrôle général de
l'ensemble des cartes tous les deux ans
je dis bien l'ensemble des cartes 300 et
quelques milles plus ce qui scelle que
nous délivrons tous les ans environ
100000 puisque le rythme de
renouvellement s'accélère et que le taux
de rotation de la profession de la
sécurité privée notamment de larguer
neige est supérieure à 70% 70% dès
agents change soit d'emploi soit
d'employeurs tous les ans ce qui amène
un taux de rotation considérables et
donc une activité permanente du clap
sans plus de du pic qui arrivent tous
les cinq ans des reprises d'activités
des reprises d'activité à temps partiel
des compléments d'activité en cas de
besoin majeur
imaginons les jeux olympiques par
exemple c'est un sujet totalement majeur
où le niveau de préparation et reste
aujourd'hui encore très faible par
rapport aux besoins qui va s'exercer et
où probablement l'ensemble de la
population titulaires d'une carte va
revenir à ce moment précis si le cnap se
suit les instructions qui ont été
données au moment de l'euro 2016 et bien
toutes les cartes toutes les cartes vont
devoir être revisitée avant
l'ouverture du processus préalable aux
jeux olympiques et toute la durée des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques donc
ceci explique l'ampleur du dispositif
nécessaire pour fonctionner mais là
l'existence tant qu'elle n'est pas
publiée au journal officiel dans ce cas
précis et d'ailleurs nous ne sommes
peut-être pas au courant de l'activité
exact de monsieur benalla à l'elysée je
ne suis pas sûr que grand monde savait
très exactement ce qu'il y faisait avant
que la presse et les commission denquête
décide de révéler ce qui était la
réalité de ces contrats à ma
connaissance
le fait qu'il ne l'indiquent pas est la
situation exacte devait être regardée au
vu des exactement ce qu'ils faisaient
des horaires qu'ils faisaient mais
l'interdît absolue en termes de code
général de la fonction publique à ma
connaissance ne s'appliquait pas à son
cas par ailleurs ne se serait pas
appliquée à sont capables
merci